how much did we make today five million
how much did we lose today a billion you
got rich dudes pissing in their pants
right now
[Music]
holy
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody roaring Kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is
GameStop I love this guy
[Applause]
retail Traders I'm hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying
the money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund make a ton of money
70 000 people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in
GameStop those shares not stopping the
stock is only going to go up when they
hit I'm gonna buy you a mansion let's
drink to that my brother is a
nerd Wall Street must be seeing this
right holy holy you
should probably dial in holy
do you have a minute I uh
um
babe how much did we make today
five million how much did we lose today
a billion and yesterday 4 million and
yesterday a billion
yeah
rich
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated
surprise surprise you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed
[Music]
in the race if you let some
steal the prize a lot of people feel the
system is broken the whole idea of the
stock market is if you're smart and
maybe with a little luck you can make
your fortune certainly not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
[Music]
pit balls
maybe now there is yeah
[Music]